hello everyone welcome to another
episode of history of science and
technology q a
happy to try and talk about history that
i've been involved in and uh history
that i might have studied
let's see i see a whole bunch of
questions here saved up
there's one here
from matt
asking can you discuss the thinking
process of discovery of complex numbers
quaternions and octonions
let's see what i can do with that
so the person who's usually credited
with sort of the arrival of complex
numbers is cardano
uh
and and the time is around 1 500.
and uh
here's the thing people were interested
in equations
solving equations things like polynomial
equations
they were interested in things like
solving quadratic equations
people learned how to solve quadratic
equations in antiquity it was certainly
known uh to the babylonians i think
certainly to the egyptians other people
knew how to solve quadratic equations
and there was sort of
they wouldn't have written the quadratic
formula in anything like the notation
that we writed in today that there was
sort of an understanding of the
quadratic formula from from antiquity
then the big challenge was what about
the cubic
um
could you solve the general cubic what
was involved in solving the general
cubic
and that was a sort of a long-term
discussion about how could you solve the
cubic
and uh
the particularly
the casus irreducibles
the the case of the irreducible cubic
um how would you solve that
and what was
what emerged
was
and um
let's see i i i'm this history is a bit
messy because there were different
people who claimed that they solved the
cubic and then they were there was a big
sort of uh a showdown at somewhere in in
italy where these guys were a chap
called tartaglia was involved and
cardano and so on and there was a sort
of a lot of intrigue and people uh
leaving the secret of the cubic to their
heirs and and then somebody else saying
they'd stolen it and all this kind of
thing a lot of other kind of intrigue
but the main thing in the end was
let us have the sort of public
demonstration of who can solve the cubic
so to speak
well to solve the cubic you need two
things you need negative numbers and you
need complex numbers and before that
time people had not thought of negative
numbers as really being a thing
yes you know you can own five sheep or
you can owe five sheep to somebody else
but the notion that there's a minus five
sheep
that you have wasn't really something
that people had identified as a definite
notion
i was thinking about this recently and i
was thinking about ages you know you can
be 10 years old but you can't really be
minus 10 years old we don't we don't
have a real meaning right now for saying
you're minus 10 years old that's
something where we just wouldn't even
discuss it because it doesn't seem to
make any sense
age is a thing where it's like it only
starts when you start to exist so to
speak and so so it then progresses over
time and so you know that gives us some
sense of why people before the 1500 or
so didn't really take complex numbers to
be a thing you should really think about
as a single package thing it's kind of
like we've got five sheep you can owe
somebody five sheep but this notion that
you can the owing of sheep is minus five
sheep so to speak
wasn't really thought about until the
cubit equation where where there really
wasn't a choice but to kind of package
together
the negative numbers as sort of things
that should be considered on their own
and turned out that along with negative
numbers came the square root of minus
one which is sort of the base of what
leads you to complex numbers so that was
kind of the uh the the cubic was what
drove both negative numbers and complex
numbers um to be introduced into the
world and i suppose
people like euler in the 1700s
had sort of really uh kind of nailed
down kind of the character of complex
numbers and you know had things like e
to the i pi
minus one those kinds of things um that
was uh
that came around that time now in terms
of quaternions
generalizations of the complex numbers
um those were really a chap called
william rowan hamilton
uh irish chap around the 1830s i think
um
what he was interested in is was there a
kind of a a system that would generalize
the complex numbers was there a way of
taking some of the some of the features
of complex numbers
just as
with ordinary numbers real numbers
whatever they have certain features
some of those features are carried over
to the complex numbers some are not like
for example you can say this real
numbers 3.7 is greater than another real
number 2.4 but with complex numbers
there's no real notion of what's greater
than what because they're not things
arranged online the things we might plug
the clock the little imaginary parts in
in a two-dimensional plane and so saying
what's to the right of what well that
might be one definition of greater than
but that's only dealing with let's say
the the real part of the number and so
on so we lose certain things going to
complex numbers but we preserve certain
other things like there's a notion of
multiplication there's a notion of
addition there are properties of
multiplication multiplication is
commutative for complex numbers a times
b is equal to b times a those kinds of
things so hamilton wanted to generalize
beyond that and this was a time in the
1830s where sort of lots of
generalization was starting to happen
1830s 1840s in mathematics
uh you know labor chefsky had talked
about how there could be non-utility in
space how there could be a place where
the parallel postulate two parallel
lines never crossed newton's fifth
postulate wouldn't be true there could
be a a space with them uh where that was
fundamentally not true galwa had started
talking about group theory and
which also was introduced as a result of
thinking about solutions to in that case
quantic equations and the impossibility
of finding a closed form formula for the
quantum equation in any case group
theory was another case where one had
taken kind of the the sort of raw
machinery of mathematics and it applied
it to things which were not things like
ordinary real numbers integers and so on
so hamilton
i think
was motivated by
by this sort of notion of generalization
it's also the case and i don't know how
much this was related to what he did
that when you deal with
three-dimensional rotations
uh you are you know in two dimensions
it's very much a story of complex
numbers you can represent sort of a
rotation in two dimensions as a
multiplication by by e to the i5 or
whatever else you can represent sort of
two-dimensional stuff going on
and transformations in two dimensions
very nicely with complex numbers what
about the three-dimensional case in
three dimensions representing a
three-dimensional rotation might be
represented by a three by three matrix
how does that work is there a formalism
an algebra similar to the algebra of of
uh of complex numbers that would apply
in three mentions and that's um
what uh i don't know to what extent that
was what hamilton was thinking about i
just don't happen to know that a piece
of history immediately but any case that
was the thing that plutonians ended up
being a way to represent
three-dimensional rotations that's
sometimes convenient sometimes not so
convenient there are different
approaches like euler angles and uh roll
pitch law other ways of representing
what does it mean to be a particular
orientation in three-dimensional space
but any case that was the the
introduction of plutoniums and people
really thought i think for a while that
quaternions were going to sort of take
over the world complex numbers were
were really cool but quaternions were
really going to be the description of
nature
complex numbers got a boost
um in the 1920s and so on when it became
clear that you could formulate quantum
mechanics in terms of complex numbers i
happen to believe based on our theory of
physics now that a little bit people
went a little bit too far with complex
numbers that they package quantum
amplitudes into this sort of a quantum
amplitude is a single complex number i
actually think that the magnitude and
the phase of that complex number are
really of separate physical origins so
that packaging of we can represent this
in terms of complex numbers probably was
a mistake but any case you know complex
numbers kind of got a bit of a boost
there
in quantum mechanics with with uh being
sort of intrinsic to that people thought
about plutonionic quantum mechanics as
sort of a generalization of ordinary
quantum mechanics but never really got
very far
and people over the course of time have
felt you know quantum that quaternions
has got to be something really
fundamental about plutoniums i should
say with plutonians that um just like in
in complex numbers there's well in real
numbers we're talking about one and you
know numbers made with multiples of one
so to speak in complex numbers we've got
one and i the square root of minus one
in quaternions we've got one i j k
there are three there are four units so
to speak that one can one could think
about and for complex numbers it's still
true that a times b is equal to b times
a for any complex numbers a and b for
quaternions that's no longer true which
earnings do not have commutativity just
as rotations in three dimensions don't
have commutativity it matters in which
order you do the rotations
so that they lose what quaternions lose
to infertility now there's a question
how far can you go beyond that
and so i think there's a chap called
clifford
um
oh boy first name forgotten
um
the uh who
uh
started to think about what was the sort
of generalized version of this how far
could you go
and um
uh this
led to um
this kind of generalizing quaternions
and the generalization of quaternions to
our the next generalization is to
octolians
and octonians lose associativity they
lose
a times b times c being equivalent to a
times b times c
um so they're another level and people
again have sometimes said well maybe
elktonians are relevant to physics maybe
they are
sort of represent some some core feature
of the symmetry of the universe so to
speak just as plutonians represent
things about symmetries and
three-dimensional space that's never
really been found to work out
uh going beyond oktonians
um you kind of lose
the the um
oh my gosh what are they called uh
algebras what are they called
sorry don't remember um
the uh
uh there's a sort of family of of things
that you can construct that start from
the reals complexes plutoniums
and it doesn't go on that that sequence
stops there at least if you want to have
certain properties be true of that of
that sequence and if you go on you get
into sort of the upper reaches of rather
abstract mathematics that hasn't really
come to uh you know hasn't really landed
anywhere but so that that's a little bit
on the history of um and i don't know
exactly what octonians date from i would
guess about 100 years ago but i'm not
sure um another person who was much
involved in this was was grassmann
um herman grassman
uh in the 1860s
was uh was very much involved in the
kind of
the accidentization of algebraic kinds
of theories
and led to this idea of grasman
variables non-commuting variables
for which x times y is not equal to y
times x and so on but thinking about
kind of that as a piece of an ordinary
algebra where you just deal with sort of
variables that in polynomials and things
that represent real numbers or represent
complex numbers you always have that
commutativity but one can go beyond that
and i think grassmann uh who is really
one of the people who
who was part of the tradition that led
to the real sort of accidentization of
things like algebra and arithmetic and
so on of saying well you know people had
in the past just sort of said well the
things that are sort of obviously true
about algebra like that x times y equals
y times x but grassmann tried to sort of
formulate that more precisely as you
know what is the axiomatic structure
that you need to have in the same sense
that euclid had defined accidents for
geometry back in antiquity it was
finally came to algebra to start
defining sort of an asthmatic framework
for that and that really only happened
in the mid-1800s
and led eventually to to things like
piano's work and and other kinds of uh
final sort of formal accidentalizations
of those theories but i think grassmann
and his work on grassmann variables and
so on was another piece of the sort of
tradition that led to kind of this this
notion of generalizing the generalizing
numbers
uh
well let's see there's a question here
um
so many different interesting questions
okay a question from the universe asking
can i talk about the history of uh
growth and leak alexander grothenbeek um
and what led to his homotopic hypothesis
i wish i knew this history in more
detail
um i don't know it in tremendously much
detail
um
alexander grothenbeek was a
a very abstract mathematician who worked
mostly in france
um and i suppose his heyday was probably
the 1960s to 1970s
and was really responsible for some very
abstract ideas which actually we get to
make use of in our physics project
and um
the uh
i mean as a the personal history of
growth is complicated and and was very
much entwined with um
uh both sort of the the um uh
uh i guess probably anarchist political
movements and then with the the um
second world war
and um uh grothenbeek himself ended up
in a um
uh
in kind of a
town in in um middle of france
um
slightly smaller smaller town um and uh
uh kind of had a uh sort of a
the powerful mathematician so to speak
who eventually kind of broke out and
became a a kind of paris based
kind of key figure in in sort of french
mathematics and invented a bunch of
things in the algebraic topology kind of
algebraic geometry kind of area um that
ascended to sort of higher and higher
levels of abstraction
um
maybe i shouldn't talk about the
technical details of what he did and the
relationship between um uh and this
homotopic uh
the the um
well essentially what growth and deep
did
was to say you can have these sort of
abstractly constructed things that are
constructed in a sense axiomatically
that are constructed by
defining relations and so on but these
are very things that are very much
things of
sort of logic what we might now think of
as computation and his claim was that in
some appropriate limit there was
inevitable geometrical character or at
least topological character to those
kinds of systems and that's very
resonant with things
that i've been interested in about how
one can go from underlying computational
stuff
to things which are like the space that
we experience in the universe and in
fact both in the
hypothesis about sort of the inevitable
geometry of these systems
is i think closely related to the the
cause of of of things like continuum
space in in our universe but growth and
leak himself
had a had a strange personal history and
i never met him um and uh he had um
uh
he was uh
you know i've read some of his works on
both mathematics
and uh kind of politics and it's kind of
interesting to see the extent to which
his kind of view of the world as this
very abstract mathematical thing
and then his view of the world as how
the world should be when it comes to
human society
as kind of a bizarre both both both both
connection and disconnection between
those views but i think the result of
this was that he kind of got very
frustrated with the kind of um uh the
reception of his more political ideas
in uh in paris and sort of uh
disappeared um and and spent the last
20-something years of his life
in um uh back in actually i think near
where he had grown up um in france and
there are lots of exotic stories about
people trying to visit him and find him
and so on actually a friend of mine
who's a well-known novelist happens to
be writing a book about um
uh sort of that is that is centered
around um
um growth and leaks ideas so i'll be
very interested to see how that how that
comes out um but uh is a very
interesting figure in sort of the the
the the most abstract end of kind of
mathematical thought in the 20th century
um
well let's see that was a uh
there's probably more to say about that
but but let me let me address some of
these other ones here
erin asks and i talk about the history
of four function calculators
um
as far as i know it let's see
i mean
the uh
uh
there were mechanical calculators
uh leibniz tried to build a four
function mechanical calculator um in the
early in the early 1700s
it didn't work very well he had a lot of
trouble with carries
because you know there was a general
problem with mechanical calculators when
you've got the 99999 add one all those
wheels have to turn over to make the one
zero zero zero that's mechanically
difficult to achieve um while while not
sort of breaking the wheels or or having
to have too much force you know you have
to there has to be more force to turn
over all those wheels yet it still has
to work even when you're only turning
one wheel and so on but that was the
history so mechanical calculators
um
they actually led to probably the most
um the pinnacle of mechanical calculus
is a thing called the curta which was
made in liechtenstein and uh in the
1950s and 1960s i guess um
i got one of those as a gift for one of
my kids actually it's this little barrel
shaped thing it's about about some you
know about fist sized object um and it's
just full of cogs inside and you set up
a calculation on it it's a purely
mechanical device it's a it's a pocket
calculator that is mechanical you set up
the the calculation on it and you turn
all these wheels and so on and then you
get the results it's really a very cool
object i mean it's it's a remarkable
that that can work purely mechanically
but that had finally been perfected um
in the 1960s and so on that kind of
technology didn't really catch on huge
huge amounts but it would be uh um a uh
you know the full function calculator
would be um
a uh
um
uh
uh
that that's sort of the mechanical
version i i'm i'm you know just to give
a sense of how history progresses if you
look at alan turing's work on on
computation he'll mention somewhere he
says well you could do that
um
in this world that way or you could use
a brunsviga
what is a brunswicker brunswicker was a
brand
sort of a dominant brand of mechanical
calculator in the time of alan turing in
that in the 1940s and so on um and
actually i found recently this very
charming advertisement for a brunswigger
which showed a bronzer on a table in an
airship
um and it was advertising you know kind
of the do your calculations anywhere
it's kind of like the laptop of the past
or something um and it's uh you know
instead of the uh
and that was the the sort of the coolest
location was on the um
uh on on the airship so to speak
so in any case
with uh calculators electronic
calculators
the um
the big thing that needed to happen
was well transistors had to be invented
and then microprocessors had to be
invented and i guess it was some uh
texas instruments that was really the
the uh you know sort of core company
in
in this is in the 1960s
in making integrated circuits that is
people could make an individual
transistor back when i was a kid you
could buy a transistor it was kind of a
cool thing you know i had sort of an
electronics
a bunch of electronics parts you know
resistors capacitors inductors and so on
and then i had like two transistors and
they were these big things that were
that you could use as uh as key elements
of circuits
but the thing that that happened in the
in the 60s i guess
um was
this idea of making an integrated
circuit where you could have a little
piece of silicon and you could by
lithography effectively by essentially a
photographic process of etching things
you could have many transistors on this
single silicon chip and that was what
kind of enabled the um
uh the development of of uh calculators
um electronic calculators that whole
notion of putting you know
microprocessors putting things on uh
miniaturizing electronics it had you
know one of its major sort of
sources of impetus was um was the space
program um another was
a strange one which was in the oil
instrumentation industry there was an
interest in having instruments that
could be put down oil wells um and you
didn't want kind of the the the sort of
the the things that were kind of uh
figuring out stuff about the rock and
oil well to be this huge hundred foot
long kinds of assemblies of electronics
because if you if you wanted your your
oil drilling to be to go around a bend
for both
well perhaps because you were trying to
kind of get the oil from that other
country where you'd have to drill
sideways a bit to get to it or for other
reasons
um you didn't want the tool that was
going to be put down the oil world to be
a huge long thing and that led companies
like slumberjay for example to be major
very profitable oil instrumentation
company to be big investors in
in kind of early microelectronics
miniaturization of electronics but
anyway the end result of all of that was
that microprocessors
started to exist and one of the early
applications of that was two calculators
and so the first calculators were i
think 19
let's see it must have been
1970 1971
the first electronic uh four function
calculators started to exist i mean i
got one see i i have to do this by by
figuring out i mean i was um
uh let's see i got the first one of
those was i was probably
10 years old maybe so that would make it
1969 1970.
so of on that time frame and so what
happened first was
that there were these uh
four function calculators that were not
terribly big um they were um i guess
there had been
yeah there were desk calculators
electronic dust tuckers maybe a couple
of years earlier than that but the
pocket handheld ones they were still a
bit bulky they weren't they weren't like
um uh you know they they were
they were still things you could sort of
readily hold in your hand but they were
kind of the size of your hand
um and those those came in first four
function ones and then then's one with
ones with memory they had a couple of
registers of memory and then
then scientific calculators came in
there were sort of basically two
competing lines of those the texas
instruments ones and the hewlett-packard
ones
and uh sort of the big the big
distinction back in the day this is 1972
1973 type time frame was texas
instruments used you typed you know two
plus three equals
and um uh or you type two
times three plus four
equals and they would give you the
answer and hp
used uh reverse polish notation
um so what it was doing was it said give
your operators give your operand so it
will be two enter
three
uh plus for example and that would push
those things on the stack and the enter
was pushing it up on the stack and then
the equal then then then you give the
operator and and so the idea was
in in in fixed notation you'd say two
plus three but you can also say plus of
two comma three or you can reverse that
and you can say two three plus
and so it was using this reverse polish
notation when they called it polish
notation this was a notation that loki
cevich had invented part of the sort of
polish school of logic in the 1930s had
come up with this kind of way of this
was this was a part of the sort of meta
modeling of mathematics kind of what was
the raw material from which you could
build up mathematics we could write down
mathematics with words with formulas and
so on but what were the underlying
elements
you know there are notions of variables
and operators
and so on and what did you really need
to have did you really need to have
parentheses do you really need to have
this and that and so loki sevich had
developed this notation that was sort of
a prefix notation
for four things now but by the way this
came out of the tradition of combinators
and so on the you know the sk
combinators of sean finkel from 1920 had
been this way of kind of representing a
sequence of operations that would
correspond to something in mathematical
logic that led to lucky ceviche's
version of this
which was then taken i don't know the
details of who figured this out at
hewlett packard
they decided to use the reverse polish
notation instead of this forward you
know operation operation operation
operand operand operand it was the
operands first and then the operator and
that was the um that was sort of the big
thing in in the um uh in the in the
early 70s of sort of this competition
between the uh
the reverse polish and the sort of
forward notation of texas instruments
and there were a lot of things where
people would say there's fewer
keystrokes you have to type to do it
with the most polish i remember i
remember this t-shirt that was
circulating this must have been 1975 or
so um which was uh
um
a uh
a t-shirt that i guess had
said enter greater than equal sign and
it was kind of a a i guess it was an hp
promotional t-shirt um that was trying
to express the fact that reverse polish
notation was better than this forward
notation for calculators but but then
uh
by the time i mean so scientific
calculators came in i think i first got
one in
1972 or three
uh
texas instruments in hp and then casio
was i think a later entrant in that um
in that space
um and that was
those calculators had um i remember the
factorial key was my favorite key and
you could get up to 69 factorial um
before the thing would overflow and go
into this sort of strange state
um one thing to know about calculators
is that uh you know computers use binary
arithmetic they represent all numbers
in
in
you know sequences of ones and zeros in
the case of um
uh
the um
um
in the case of uh
uh
calculators
they tend to use binary coded decimal
so instead of actually representing
things in binary which is sort of the
natural way for a computer with with
transistors that can be on and off and
so on to represent things they pack into
uh
three binary digits they pack
a decimal number
right or is it four um i'm
must be four
um
binary digits corresponds to it to a
decimal number um
the uh uh and the reason they do that is
because it was considered too confusing
if you type one over three one-third you
get a result it's to finite precision on
a calculator then you say times three
what do you get back
well in the way when you use ordinary
binary you won't get back one you'll get
back 0.99999
and that was deemed too confusing and so
in binary coded decimal you get back
exactly one for that kind of computation
so that's kind of a difference between
computers and calculators that existed
at that time uh but then there were
other developments i mean i remember
this must have been 1980
1983 maybe four visiting japan and um
uh being very excited that i could buy a
credit card sized uh literally a credit
card calculator and i carried that
around for
for two decades or something in my in my
you know along with credit cards i
carried around this little calculator um
that was uh
a um
solar powered light powered um uh credit
card sized calculator um and that was
that was something that was uh had
become possible i guess around the early
1980s so that's that's a little bit of
the story of of what i know about um
history of four hundred calculators i
mean the thing that the programmability
of calculators became a thing i remember
the hp 35 for example an early hula
packet calculator one of the things they
did was they had these application packs
where you would get these little little
things
no it wasn't it was beyond the hp 35 it
was
something along
uh in that family of calculators you
would get these little magnetic cards
that you could stick into the calculator
that would um
give it some particular set of formulas
that will be useful for some particular
application area and that was kind of a
big thing at that time
um and then later on by the
by the 1980s i guess there started to be
things like the financial calculators
and so on that had you know time value
of money calculations on them and and
things like this
um and i think then
much later there was an attempt to sort
of uh do um
uh algebraic computation on calculators
and uh there was a
a uh a system called new math created by
a couple of people in hawaii um
who uh actually both
in their sort of semi-retirement have
done a lot of interesting things with
wolfram language and mathematica
um
the things that um
that
um
new math
uh product was actually for a while
distributed by microsoft
was not a particularly happy experience
i think for microsoft it just wasn't as
big a seller as an operating system or
something um and then that turned into a
thing called derive that ended up
getting bought by texas instruments and
became kind of the uh the foundation for
sort of some early algebraic type
calculators um that came out there um i
think those are calculators that are
still still in use today um i haven't
really followed the world of calculators
in so much detail um i all i all i hear
is that um uh you know over the years
we've interacted with all these various
calculator manufacturers and um uh one
of the things was could you run a
mathematica on a device with disposable
batteries and i remember saying
years ago saying to these calculated
manufacturers you know there'll come a
time when people don't care about
disposable batteries anymore and i was
then amused when steve jobs made the
decision in the iphone just don't let
people take the batteries out
it just doesn't it doesn't there's no
reason to have ubx able to exchange the
batteries and um clearly that's uh uh a
thing
in um
uh that uh that finally i don't know
whether it's come to calculators or
whether that's still disposable
batteries and calculators um i think
that the uh uh
one of the things in fact we built oh
nearly 10 years ago now uh we built a
very nice um kind of uh
wolfram engine powered calculator for
the ipad um that involves some very
interesting user experience design
because you know when you're putting in
a thousand functions you can't have a
thousand buttons on your ipad ux you
have to have other ways to do it and so
that's actually where we invented this
predictive interface that we've used in
notebooks uh for a long time since was
invented for our calculator product the
calculator product was never released
um and we may still one day release it
um but it's sort of the ultimate uh you
know powered by wolfram engine with all
the sort of capabilities mathematica but
it packaged into a calculator running on
the ipad that was sort of that that
might have been the ultimate end point
of some kind of uh calculator evolution
but in practice what's happened is that
people use wolfram alpha um and uh
that's you know a lot of the the
calculator's story has turned into a
just get the answers from alpha um the
only place where that hasn't happened
yet
um is in standardized testing um i mean
i i must say that i i don't consider it
one of the finest moments in in kind of
the structure of how things work that uh
you know there's still this idea you
know the kid who's going to take the
such and such test you need a 100
calculator to do it that's kind of goofy
given that you know on computers and
particularly as these tests move to a
computer environment um you really can
just you know it's just software and you
say well everybody should have the same
software well that's a different story
but or it's costly with the same
capabilities um but that's a different
thing and it's kind of a the notion of
the the the handheld you can pick it up
and it's separate from your phone it's
separate from your computer calculator i
think it's one of those kinds of things
that right now is surviving as a sort of
a bit of an anomaly from the structure
of uh kind of things like standardized
testing and so on and i think that's
some uh probably not
not one of those things that will
i don't think that let me tell a story
that perhaps is amusing um
so this was ten years ago now probably
um we were building our calculated
product and i had a lot of internal
disagreement with our company was it
worth building this thing did anybody
even care about calculators anymore and
we had a summer school which we do every
year and we have our summer camp for
high school students which we also do
every year we've been doing for a long
time
and so i i thought let me let me do a
focus group and find out what people
think about calculators so i did this
with the high school kids and they're
like make your calculator you really
should make it calculator it'll be so
cool and there are all these different
things you can do with a calculator do
it with college students and graduate
students and so on i like should we make
this calculator they're like what
you know why do you want to make a
calculator we don't care about
calculators well that's irrelevant waste
of time bad use of resources and so on
um
so uh in any case that that um
uh
the um
uh that was kind of that was ten years
ago now and i i don't know i should
probably redo that test i i've really
been wanting to it's such a lovely
exercise and user experience we had
figured out the user experience for
something the size of an ipad of kind of
the predictive interface and all these
things with buttons and being able to do
all these different kinds of things it's
a really very cool user interface um but
then it was like well let's do the same
thing for a phone
and then it's like oh my gosh that's
even more complicated don't know how to
do that so we that's what's one reason
we never released that product um but
it's something i've really wanted to do
so people think we should do it you know
send us mail because um uh it's
something i'd love to get evidence that
we should do this
uh
let's see
oh boy
um
so many interesting questions there i
see is asking tell us when when was
cyber security considered an important
topic in computer science
you know i think
people
had known about
certain kinds of what we now call
exploits
a long time ago i mean i remember
hearing
must have been before 1970 i remember
hearing about this thing oh these
students at mit and they figured out
that if you keep typing into a password
field eventually the characters will end
up going somewhere else in computer
memory and you can break into the
computer and that was kind of a
mysterious
kind of idea
that um that that could happen that was
kind of a a sort of a a
you know one of those oh did you know
about this kind of weird thing that
happened so that was kind of a the very
early days um when it wasn't when there
wasn't any kind of organized sense of
this being an important thing
i think uh
the the thing that really
uh a lot of people would view as being
the sort of the the earliest moment when
when sort of cyber security became a
more of a thing was the morris worm um
robert morris who i i
suddenly met actually met when he was a
kid
um
who uh
uh
ended up i i don't know all the details
of this but was uh um ended up releasing
onto the internet
um i mean
the story is a bit more complicated
because his his dad had been a
researcher at bell labs uh who i knew a
bit when i was a consultant at bell labs
back in the early 80s and had been a
computer security researcher for the
government and other places
um and i i suppose that gives evidence
that there was a field of computer
security that was of interest to things
like att bell labs and so on um back by
in the 19 in the early 1980s and so on
but it wasn't a thing that was generally
known but the next generation there
happened to be uh creating a
a computer worm
um and piece of what we would now call
malware um which uh when he was a
student at cornell which sort of got
released onto the internet and went and
infected lots of computers and it was a
self-replicating piece of software that
started just taking over computers i was
very proud because uh in a sense because
our network this was 1989 i think um our
network at wolverham research
was not affected by this because
i had sort of realized so good question
how did i know this
um
how did i know to be worried about this
good question
um
so that must have been some pre-history
to computer security because i knew that
one should be worried about how one
connected to the internet and what
strange creatures might come from the
internet so to speak and so i used a um
a japanese workstation made by sony
corporation it's a very weird computer
with a japanese language operating
system and so on we used that as the
gateway computer to the internet that
time
um possibly because it wasn't our most
valuable computer for the things we were
mostly doing but also because i
certainly knew that it was a thing
to sort of be obscure in the way you
connect to the internet and when the
morris worm was created um it
was
compiled for many it was you know an
executable program compiled for many
common kinds of computers but not for
this weird japanese computer system and
so our network was not affected but many
people were and i think that that is uh
there was a time when a lot of people
woke up to the fact that oh it really
matters you know what what creatures are
coming from the internet now i i
realized that i must have known
well i certainly was very aware of in
encryption and cryptography because i
had worked on
uh
well okay so so back when i was working
on smp the sort of forerunner of
mathematical northern language back in
1979 to 1982
one of the more ridiculous things that
mistakes in a sense that i made was i
thought let's protect the source code of
this that's encrypted and so i used an
encryption scheme
that um uh so in those days
encryption
was a thing you did but it was not very
well understood
and for example the unix script program
was sort of a standard thing to use to
encrypt things and that was based on
essentially the enigma codes that have
been used in in world war ii and it was
based on sort of a rotor machine
emulated in software and that was kind
of almost the state of the art for some
everyday encryption the the sort of for
more uh kind of serious encryption was
more des the data encryption standard
that had been developed um by some
combination of ibm and and national
bureau standards
and it was it was a government uh thing
and it was it was based on these very
substitution permutation type uh
sequence of things s boxes and so on um
and actually i many years later i
learned that the design of des was based
on research that had been done on
systems that are basically cellular
automata back in the 1950s uh by
mathematicians who had been associated
with the national security agency and so
on um
and uh actually very people had sort of
wondered why why are these particular
substitutions used in des and the answer
is related to various properties of of
cellular automaton-like systems that
have been studied in any case that was
the kind of that was the hardware way of
doing encryption and back at that time
in the early 80s sort of the story was
very much
um
there were
um
um
there were kind of um
um
uh there were there were kind of there
was sort of a mystery about how
encryption's uh equipment worked and
that was a time when i think uh
uh swiss and israeli
um those were two sort of sources of of
encryption
uh equipment um and it was very much
of the the nature of you know don't you
know nobody knows how the box works
inside so to speak in modern times it's
very much this kind of the algorithm is
open it's kind of mathematics that
prevents you from breaking the
encryption rather than just nobody knows
how the box works inside and that was
part of the security of things i mean i
remember i can i suppose tell a story
from 1984
um when uh
uh
let's see i think almost everybody
involved in the story is now dead so
it's probably a story that can be told
um it's uh was a story of um a physicist
who's rather a risk-taking fellow
who was trying to put together a sort of
physicist's will um
will solve problems for the world
um type of company
uh that he was trying to get me involved
in
and um uh it was a company where
one of its one of its early sort of gigs
was
make an encryption system
and the requirement was
that the u.s government cannot break in
one week
and it was a gig being done for a bank
actually um and uh the uh it was a very
very kind of um
let's say a a dubious kind of setup
because essentially i think the the
objective was to to find somebody who
would sell out sort of various
government secrets for large amounts of
money to be able to answer the question
of what could the us government not
break in one week um but uh uh through
sort of being on the on the distant
periphery of of of that
uh company that was being put together
um it was interesting to see the kind of
the the the collection of of um of sort
of there's this weird sort of encryption
thing that's been invented by this
person and it's all a lot of mystery
about how these encryption systems work
and that kind of um uh uh well that sort
of gave way to things like rsa
encryption that came in in 82 83 84 that
kind of time frame um maybe that had
been maybe that was on the horizon but
it just wasn't thought to be and it
wasn't uh sort of a practical form of
encryption still isn't it's it's
relevant for key exchange it's not
relevant for the the big sort of you
know once you're in motion encrypting
things
um
but i think this notion of of uh kind of
studying
uh sort of malware and and how that
works and so on i think that was a i'm
trying to think how that really
came in i mean um there are other pieces
to this story
uh that there are different moments when
people really become aware of computer
security the morris worm was one of them
another one was the whole story around
kevin mitnick and
this uh what became really a media
frenzy type story
uh that i suppose i can tell pieces of
here um that um yeah i can tell i think
this is a story i i i don't think it's
harmful to tell um
a person called satomu shimamura
who was um i suppose could be thought of
as a protege of mine who i knew when he
was probably
17-ish
when i was at caltech
uh back in the um
beginning of the 1980s
um and he was a sort of a
a
sort of starting out as an undergraduate
there although it didn't that didn't
last very long
but uh sutomu was a um uh very
um
uh kind of i would say a very um
kind of a computer
uh knew a lot about computers and um a
very impressive kind of computer
knowledgeable person i remember
just a lot of very detailed things about
about how computers work and he was
certainly quite aware of computer
security back um even in those days i do
have to tell a story about tsutomu that
um is an irresistible sort of personal
story because it's just kind of fun um
satomo was was always um uh
uh sort of complaining about the fact
that his parents were you know come from
japan and they lived in the u.s for ages
and they didn't even speak english and
they were just total losers and so on
and then
uh
you know it's hard hard to tell kids
kids say that about their parents from
time to time but um um uh but anyway one
of the sort of stories that he told was
the uh saying well he he'd spent all
this time when he was a kid you know
collecting jellyfish on beaches
in uh in washington state it's like okay
i i mean i i happen to remember that
that um that story of satoma collecting
jellyfish um i don't know why i even
remember the story but it was kind of
one of his uh you know uh proof of
parental
something or other okay so years go by
and um uh there's a thing called gfp the
jellyfish the the protein that leads to
bioluminescence and jellyfish
and uh many years like go by and
eventually there's a nobel prize awarded
for um
uh
the um uh for the discovery of that of
that protein and the the person who won
that prize turns out to be tsitoma's
father
and so this kind of fitted together the
um the jellyfish collection story with
the other things about the losing
parents who happen to win nobel prizes
and and things like that so i i just
found that amusing as a as a kind of a
backstory to to things but anyway
tsutomu
um
was uh uh
actually ended up um
sort of after kind of dropping out of
caltech kind of ended up at los alamos i
guess through me in some way um i was a
consultant at los alamos for a while and
um
uh
the tsutomo had a terrible habit of
breaking into computers and then people
would sort of have to fish him out of
trouble because it's like no no he's not
really trying to break into that
government's secret computer um and um
actually i now they think about it i
remember a story from
tsutomu's youth there's another computer
security story about breaking into a
computer system by the fact that two
computers were both able to access the
same printer and being able to go in
from one computer and kind of come out
from um uh from from the other computer
so so to speak
so
so tomo
um
uh time goes by and you know he's been
working at los alamos i think then he
ended up working in san diego
supercomputer center and um then one day
a chap called kevin mitnick i've never
met um
uh well somebody breaks into tomorrow's
computer and satomo is all upset because
it's like he's supposed to be this you
know sophisticated computer person and
how could somebody break into his
computer
um and so he starts this big you know
he's going to find who broke into his
computer
and um
that became this sort of big chase of
who broke into thomas computer and
somehow john markov who's a reporter at
the new york times got involved in this
and sort of satomo and john markov were
kind of running around the country
trying to track down you know who broke
into thomas computer and and i guess
that same person had broken into a bunch
of other computers around the country
and so on eventually was traced to this
chap called kevin mitnick um who uh uh i
think was in many ways very similar to
tomo except for the fact that sutomu had
had all kinds of friends like me
who were sort of continually fishing him
out of trouble so to speak and kevin
mitnick didn't have that same kind of
network of um of people who are going to
explain no no he broke into that
computer but he really meant no harm
type thing um and you know you should
just consider him a a um
anyway so so i think the um um
uh so i was a little annoyed because i
felt that tsutomu was was kind of
presenting himself as the kind of the um
uh the the sort of the good guy so to
speak who was catching the bad guy so to
speak and i i really didn't see as much
distinction as some as as he wanted to
portray but that whole thing became a
book that that sutomo wrote with with
john markoff they even became a movie
although i don't think it's a it was
another very successful movie but but um
and i
i tried to watch it it was not very
watchable at least as far as i was
concerned but anyway that was um that's
a that's another sort of uh story of of
um of computer security maybe i can tell
a few computer security stories related
to um our company which are probably
harmless to tell so i'll tell a story
from um
this must be the early 1990s
um
and uh
yeah the the um this was a story
of um
a computer gets computers get broken
into somehow
and um
it was a um
it was yeah it must have been just after
the web was starting to to come into
existence
and um
we
with some
we tracked down i can't remember quite
how we tracked down that there's some
chat room where people are exchanging
passwords that they got from this place
or that place
and um eventually it's kind of uh we
kind of identify that the handles of
people in these chat rooms i don't know
um so somehow it's some kid
young
i don't know
15 year old ish
in ohio in somewhat rural ohio who'd
been responsible for you know the actual
you know typing the password to get into
our computer it wasn't clear they'd done
any harm to our computer they broke it
into it they'd stored some random stuff
on our computer uh computer system
hadn't necessarily done any harm to it
and then it became clear that there was
sort of a a mastermind to this whole
thing
who was another kid who lived in
virginia
who um
who had a website and the website
explained i think it was a website yeah
explained that he was raising he was
kind of fed up with school and he was
going to raise an internet army to kind
of take over the world
so it's like okay um you know it's
interesting sounds like an interesting
kid
um you know better if they're not
causing lots of trouble but anyway so we
were we were like um you know i was
thinking maybe let's just contact this
kid you know
sounds interesting um although we were
sort of put off because we ended up in
this you know having this sort of
discussion with the chat room and told
this person and you know sort of contact
the person and within a few seconds you
can see that this person is is trying to
break into the computer of the person
who's connecting to the chat room that
is trying to have that is having a
polite conversation with this kid so
that was like this is this is clearly a
a there's sort of danger involved here
so so the fbi got involved in this whole
thing
and um it was uh it was a it was a i
mean these were the early days of
computer security i suppose but it was
definitely a a difficult situation
because
there was this kid in ohio who was very
clearly identifiable as sort of the the
person who had who had broken into our
computers and it ended up you know a
week went by when it was pretty clear
that that you know who that was and they
knew that we knew and all this kind of
thing and somehow that turned into some
some terrible you know police raid on
some some random street in in ohio um in
some small town uh you know a week later
uh you know kind of long after any
evidence that there might have been have
been destroyed and so on and so on and
so on it didn't really seem any way that
this was
so that was kind of it to me it was a
somewhat heavy-handed response to that
situation but the problem was that the
the kid in virginia um who happened to
live not not far away from the
what was then i had no idea of today uh
sort of a computer crimes uh unit
um uh
in the government
and um we certainly talked to them about
this and they were like but this is too
complicated this person has you know
people in 200 jurisdictions you know how
are we going to deal with this this was
sort of an early example of of what has
happened in a lot of sort of distributed
uh computer activity and so on and that
was it was kind of a um you know that
was sort of the early days of seeing the
interaction between kind of the the uh
and that the basic point was he sharded
a bunch of of data across you know 200
different people in his internet army so
to speak and i am curious i should look
up for what what happened to that kid
i'm i'm curious what um uh what became
of them i i was sort of sorry that i i
felt it was sort of too dangerous to
have
to contact them
um i i mean i could tell i could tell
lots of these computer security stories
of different kinds of times when when
things have happened and um uh and sort
of this increasing awareness
um
that i mean there's certain kinds of of
um
of things where one has sort of a you
know at every moment i suppose it's like
it's like i don't know airplane crashes
or something like that every major one
that happens people say how did that
happen
and then you learn from that and then
that particular one you know the metal
fatigue one doesn't happen again and
then this one doesn't happen again and
so on and so it has been with computer
security as a series of different uh
things you know happened for the first
time and then the world reacts to them i
mean like for example in recent times
the solar winds uh thing in the neo4j
uh you know exploits
um really put highlighted this notion of
software supply chains of and this is
kind of one of the one of the various
problems with the open source software
and so on is there these chains of sort
of libraries and things where it's kind
of like somebody can commit something to
something which leads to some whole
chain of of things changing and so on
but also there's this whole question of
where did that software ultimately come
from and when you're delivering a piece
of software to somebody you know does it
have you know what what dependencies
does it have on all these things which
may end up having having different
exploits that exist against them i mean
i suppose in in the world today you know
one of the things i i suppose it's uh
pretty well known how this works i mean
there you know people are always looking
for exploits you know is there a bug in
this operating system is there a way to
break into this phone and you know have
it do this or that weird thing
and you know there's a there's a
continual effort to do that it's done by
governments it's done by private
uh organizations
and uh you know private organizations
you're kind of like
uh if you discover a an exploit you know
the most the most valuable are the
zero-day exploits the exploits which
haven't been seen before so the zero day
is the thing where it's day zero you
know it hasn't been seen by the time
it's day five kind of everybody knows
about that exploit and people kind of
patched for it but on day zero it's like
you get to attack things and nobody
knows to defend against them so to speak
and so you know there's a certainly the
the rumor certainly would be that um you
know the us government will pay twice as
much or three times as much or something
as anybody else but you have to sell
exclusively to them if you're a maker of
such such things and sort of it's
inevitable this is a feature of the
whole theoretical framework of of
computation and computational
irritability and so on it's inevitable
that there will be such bugs it's not a
oh you know the world's incompetent and
people should be able to track down
every possible bug it's inevitable that
as soon as you have computational
systems that are capable of of
sophisticated computation that there
will be these unexpected consequences
and that's kind of the theoretical basis
of why why cyber security is hard is you
know as soon as you have if you have
that thing that's just a router that's
connecting this to that and it's just a
couple of wires nothing much
can be done with that but as soon as
your router has intelligence maybe it's
a firewall maybe it's something else
that has you know intelligence and it
has actual algorithms that it's running
as soon as it's a general purpose
computer then in principle you can make
that general purpose computer do things
for purposes other than the ones that it
was intended to do things for so to
speak in other words once once there's
this once it reaches this level of
computational universality then it is
potentially exploitable and that's the
kind of theoretical basis for the
difficulty of cyber security and it's
then becomes this question of what did
you want that router to be able to do
well you have some theorem some
statement i don't want the router to be
able to do this and then you can try and
verify that and there's sort of a an
effort which has not been particularly
successful yet to use sort of automated
theorem proving techniques and so on to
say let's just verify this piece of
software only does what we say it will
do the problem with that is you have to
have a description language for what you
say it will do and if if the description
of what you don't want it to do is
straightforward like oh you don't want
it to scribble on memory that doesn't
have access to or some such other thing
then then that might be a thing you can
you can verify but if it's more oh i
don't want it to do something different
from what i thought it should do
that requires that you have you know the
what you thought it should do is defined
by the code that you originally put in
the then if you say i don't want to do
something different you have to have
another piece of essentially code that
defines what you want it to do and it
doesn't really help you very much
um
so
uh
the um oh sandra is asking are there are
the hackers at our company look for
exploitable bugs
um in our systems uh the answer to that
is yes
um and uh you know this is a this is a
standard thing that any any company will
do is is to try and uh if you can find
uh exploits yourself it's it's better
than um that having the world find them
the challenge is always once you find
potential exploits it's like how do you
fix them and sometimes there's a there's
a cost to fixing them and sometimes
takes a while to fix them and and so
it's like you know you don't want to
like put on a bulletin board here's an
exploit we haven't fixed it yet um and
so that's always a a challenge to to see
what you best do with that
um
let's see
uh
oh yeah yeah somebody somebody pointing
out something which i'm i'm forgetting
here from happy here um
cyber security for the phone system yeah
i mean there used to be these things i
sort of a little bit before my time they
call blue boxes or something which were
things where
yeah this is this is a this is a fun
kind of thing
so
you know
on the phone system
in a sense the only interface to the
phone system was a phone
back in the day and so you would always
be just dialing a number on the phone
whatever you want to do with the phone
system you got by dialing a number on
the phone
and so there were uh you know things
like make a call you know pay a toll
this kind of thing they were all
represented by essentially numbers on
the phone or by the time touch tones
came in so the you know originally
rotary dial phones were where you just
have this this dial and you turn it
around and then it's you know this is
the reason why in the us the area codes
for you know new york is you know
uh
2-1-2 los angeles is chicago is 3-1-2
los angeles is 2-1-3 these kinds of
things the big cities have small
numbered area codes and only dinosaurs
like me actually memorize area codes
because who cares anymore but but um the
um uh
in in um
the reason that there were small digit
area codes for the big cities was that
on a rotary dial phone the way that your
uh
the way that you can tell what number
you're calling is you you turn the dial
and then the dial kind of has a spring
and it kind of goes back to its original
state again and it goes
click click click click click
one click for every number it goes past
so when you dial a two it's just got two
clicks it doesn't take very long if you
dial like a zero it's got lots and lots
and lots of clicks as it goes as it goes
around uh sending those clicks down the
phone line as its way to describe the
you know as its way to essentially
transmit data
so that was the original so
approach well the very original approach
was you just pick up the phone and a
phone operator is there sort of at the
other end of that wire and it's going to
connect things together but as soon as
standard trunk dialing of of going of
dialing over sort of trunk lines that
went long distances and so on started
one had to have things like these rotary
dial phones that would transmit their
signals in that way so then touchstones
came in
and
i remember
uh
well so touch tones this kind of clever
idea where you have these these sort of
two
linear changes of of uh frequency level
uh on the two x and y directions across
the phone across the the numbers on on a
phone dial on phone you know where push
buttons on a phone and these two
frequencies
and uh they the
the the the frequencies change as as you
go in the x direction with the numbers
and the other one changes in the y
direction and you're playing these two
frequencies at the same time and it's
hard to whistle two frequencies at the
same time you know birds have syrinxes
that allow them to sort of uh uh sing
sort of different frequencies at the
same time we humans have a vocal tract
that doesn't allow us to do that so you
don't get to whistle the touch tones
very well
um so but that was the sort of the way
that you sent data from phones was these
touch tones
and uh the um i remember when i was a
consultant at bell labs
that um some of the people who'd
invented that technology were there
and um they they always they described
and i never really got to the bottom of
this they they described that they had a
device that would just generate somehow
could make any phone call anywhere and
could sort of access the phone system in
any way that you chose by just giving it
the right touch tone so to speak but i
never really got to the bottom of what
that quite was
um but um
in any case back in the 70s i guess
people uh
uh it was a it was a a
sort of silicon valley area popular
thing and i think steve jobs was
involved in this and and so on other
people who are making these little boxes
that would allow you to make free phone
calls because they would send the
signals the touchstone signals that
would represent some billing uh you know
the the back in the day it was like make
a a reverse charged call or something or
make a third-party build call and all of
that was represented by
touch tones and i remember i gosh i
don't even know whether this is still a
thing there used to be telephone credit
card numbers which were
numbers that were associated with your
phone number um and with had some extra
digits um and you know when you would
make a phone call you could key in the
number you were calling and then you
would key in your credit card number
which was your phone credit card number
and everything was touchstones so
everything was transmitted that same way
and so that was kind of an early sort of
piece of hacking was just send weird
touch tones to the phone um and i don't
know exactly how those blue box things
worked but i think that they just knew
the codes that were being used to to
sort of operate the phone system a
certain way i do have to tell one story
about this so i was this was 1981
or 82
and i was in england
um and uh was a time when actually i was
working on smp
uh forerunner to mathematical
multilanguage and so on and uh for
various reasons i was using the computer
of a friend of mine who had a computer
company in england
and uh we were sort of camping out for a
couple of weeks doing a bunch of stuff
on his computer system and i needed to
transfer some data uh i think from the
us
and uh so at that time it was using
acoustic coupled modems
so you would you would like pick up the
phone and you would you know put the
phone into these rubber cups the
physical phone receiver into these
rubber cups and if you listen you know
if you pull it out of the rubber cup you
would hear it chirping as it sent data
in in you know as audio signals and the
the the um modem would be in modulating
demodulating it would be taking those
acoustic signals and turning them back
into digital data and so on okay so
anyway so i tried to do this and it
doesn't work
and um the uh
this was a transatlantic call and in
those days transatlantic calls were many
of them were made by satellite
but there were a limited number of
transatlantic cables and it was it was
not quite as you know it wasn't as sort
of routine and fiber optic and so on as
it is today so anyway so this was a
sunday evening i think
and um i'm trying to make this work and
it doesn't work it doesn't work we call
the
operator say we're trying to do this
call you know what's going on what's
going on and eventually
like
you know we get transferred to this
person to that person that person and
eventually we get transferred to the
person who who appeared to be i i think
maybe even said they were sort of the
chief engineer
in the in the uk phone system on duty
that evening he said what are you trying
to do so try and do this says well why
don't you dial star such and such and
such some four-digit thing he says that
will switch off the echo suppressor and
will allow you to get you know data to
transmit correctly and it indeed worked
but it was kind of amusing that there
was this code that you just typed in it
was a phone number you know it was a
piece of a phone number so to speak that
would switch off some piece of the of
the of the infrastructure that was
dealing with well that in that case it
was probably echo suppression because of
something to do with the way that the
the um phone signals were being
transmitted by different through
different um i don't know through cables
and satellites and so on um but i just
to me it was kind of a notable thing
first of all that that it was possible
at least in england at that time that
there was a sort of inevitable there's a
you know a chief engineer on duty at
some time and that if you go through
enough levels of phone calls you
eventually get to that person and they
can just tell you dial this number and
um uh and it will change the
characteristics of the phone system in
some kind of electronics type way
because the only interface to the phone
system is dying phone numbers
um and certainly you know there are
certainly myths about the idea that you
know if you dial exactly the right phone
numbers you can start you know
uh doing all kinds of crazy things in
the whole infrastructure of of uh of the
us and so on
um
anyway
uh
slr asks if nature is fundamentally
computational then what are the bugs in
nature
the bugs in nature are the things we
don't expect
they're the things that if
if
if we think we know the laws of nature
and then we say well what are the
consequences of those laws
the bugs are the things that we didn't
expect the things that are
the you know if you if you think you
make up a theory of gravity who expected
black holes
um they're the that's what a bug in a
sense is in a program you think you made
a program that does a particular thing
but actually the program crawls out and
does something different
and and that's that's the nature of bugs
there
um
let's see
i think i have just a couple more
minutes here um
aaron is asking can i talk about steve
jobs next step approach to software does
it have an ongoing legacy funny you
should ask that question so i've been
going back and i've been writing this
piece which hopefully we got finished
real soon about the making of the new
kind of science book of mine which which
started in 1991
and uh actually that was 1991 was when i
switched to using next computers
um and so i was we were just trying to
reconstruct
the um uh software that i'd be using at
that time and we found a virtualized
emulation of the next computer
and um uh in fact just this morning
the uh person who does uh computer
system stuff for me was bemoaning the
fact that he managed to get this next
step
interface up and running and he was
disappointed that it wasn't
more
interesting than it was because he said
when he'd been in college back in the
day you know he'd sort of uh lustered
after the next computers which he didn't
have access to because he thought they
were super cool
and now he finally has you know is using
next step because we got it working in
this virtual machine for this historical
reconstruction that i'm doing and he's
like oh it's not that interesting and i
was pointing out the reason it doesn't
look that interesting to you is because
a lot of those user interface features
are things that became part of the
standard canon of user interface
technology subsequent to that time at
the time they were they were really
notable and uh and later they they you
know they became you know partly when
next was absorbed into apple again and
so on they kind of became par for the
course for how user interfaces work
you know i think there are many things
about next step that were interesting i
mean one of them was postscript was its
native uh rendering environment so
everything that was on the screen was
being rendered through postfit
postscript was this page description
language that was originally developed
for the laser printers um it was uh and
originally the apple laserwriter was the
first uh uh thing that used postscript
made by adobe um made by john warnock
and chuck geshke and so on um
in uh
and postscript was um
uh
the um uh you know that there was sort
of this there had been a a zoo of
different sort of standards for how you
control your laser printer but then
there was this kind of fairly clean
actually reverse polish based as it
turns out language for
um
uh
is it reverse or is it forward polish oh
it's reverse polish um
language for describing uh how to draw
vector things and so on and particularly
how to draw fonts how to draw the spline
curves of fonts and so on uh bezier
curves of fonts um to make to form
letters
um the the um that was you know because
letters you know how do you make a
letter this was the thing that people
had kind of uh you know i think albert
jura has a book about this from
when was it the
1400s something like that am i right am
i off by centuries i'm not sure but but
um making font characters forming
letters you know back in the time in
antiquity people were forming letters
the stone masons were forming letters by
you know uh chipping them out of things
and so on and there's this sort of
question as they became more you know
how do you describe a letter is a letter
a combination of circles and straight
lines well no it's not quite that it's
something a little bit different than
that mathematically when it got
mathematicized it's really pieces of
cubic curves are a typical way to make
the forms that we use to construct
letters to make fonts and so on and that
got kind of captured in postscript as
bezier curves and such like um that that
had been originally made
for uh bezier curves were originally
made i think by um
uh well two competing technologies one
was boeing uh people at boeing dealing
with uh airfoil design and one was
people at i think citron in france
dealing with kind of car design i have
to say that the um
well i had an interesting experience
back in the early 90s visiting some car
companies and things and talking about
the ways that they describe geometries
and uh one company was like uh they were
saying well yeah we really want to get
into using splines and things like that
but we're still stuck in sort of
piecewise linear and it's like oh that's
why the cars of that company look kind
of boxy so to speak is because that's
the mathematics that they're using to
describe the shapes of cars
um but anyway let's see we were talking
about some postscript
and so
uh one of the things that was originally
steve jobs's sort of idea was to use
postscript as the description language
on the apple laserwriter and there was
sort of this funny thing that the the
processor inside the laser printer was
more powerful than the processor on the
mac that was driving it so when early
desktop publishing came in part of what
made that possible was the fact that the
laser printer was running postscript you
could have these beautiful fonts and so
on
bezier curves where the final figuring
out of which actual pixels would get
turned on and off happened inside the
printer what the what the computer was
sending was just this postscript
description of you know draw this curve
with this cubic function but then the
printer was what was rendering it so one
of the things that then happened with
the next step was that the screens had
not been done that way before screens
like on sun workstations for example
were bitmaps you would just assemble
with a bunch of operations this is the
assembly of bits of of um that were on
the screen black it's on the screen
but the next step there was the idea of
using postscript and one feature that
had was whatever you had on the screen
was described in this resolution
independent way in terms of vector
graphics and if you wanted to print it
even though the printer was higher
resolution than the screen you would
immediately get a good a good rendering
of that
that was one kind of thing i think that
the other thing that was a big kind of
idea was interface builder on next i
have to say i never really used that
myself we used it in the creation of um
uh of the user interface the next i mean
the history of this was for us
back in 1987 we were developing
mathematica
and uh through um
a couple of connections uh i
ended up um
interacting with steve jobs who at that
point was um thinking of next as a
company was going to make computers for
the higher education market
and um
uh we kind of made this deal
manika will be bundled on every next
computer and steve paid us some modest
amount of money per computer for that um
for the privilege of doing that so to
speak
um and uh that was um and so so we kind
of got involved in working on the next
computer before the next computer was
was out it was released in late 1988 i
think
um
and actually i happened to just find a
few days ago um an email that i sent to
steve jobs uh back in 1987
at a time when he was really interested
in what could he bundle on the next
computer what kind of stuff you know
there's a certain amount of storage he
was using optical disks as a storage
medium and they were had a lot more
density than than other kinds of things
what could he put on the next machine
that would be useful to people so i i we
were talking about i don't know who
invented this term maybe him maybe me i
don't know of reference ware as a as a
thing a bit like software but it was
like things you would make references to
and so i i sent him this mail um
actually i think it must have been a
physical i think it was it was typed on
a computer but sent in a physical form
somehow maybe as a fax maybe as a
physical mail i don't really remember
but um in any case it was a description
a few pages description of different
kinds of things that you could have as
reference material it's kind of amusing
reading um it's talking about how well
some of the mathematical reference
material is going to be irrelevant
because of mathematica which was at the
time when this was being that i wrote
that note in 1987 the working name that
we had for it at that time was polymath
so that's what the note refers to anyway
i just tweeted out this note a few days
ago it's kind of fun to see as a kind of
historical artifact of how one was
thinking about things in those days and
i was talking about you know maps will
be a good kind of reference material but
they're very big and they're not going
to fit and so on and uh
you know talking about other kinds of
reference material one might have but
anyway so
so back in those days we were working on
the next actually teo gray
uh long time person at our company who's
gone off and done all kinds of other
interesting things particularly around
chemistry um but teo was the person who
was the original developer of the
notebook interface for
for our
technology stack back in 1987
and was developed partly on the mac but
partly on the next
and teo was was living in california at
the time and was going over to to um
uh palo alto uh where next was next to
taken over the facilities of xerox park
at 33 30 33 33 coyote hill road if i
remember right um the uh um
and um
uh they were very steve was always very
kind of um secretive about how things
worked and so uh teo would have to
physically go there and there were you
know guards at every at every point so
to speak and and work on the next
computer and develop but this was before
the next computer was out and about
um i and uh uh
developed um
uh the first version of mathematica and
the so the best first interface first
user interface for mathematica was
developed on the next computer and
that's where kind of the notebook
paradigm was in large part developed on
on the next computer um along with
macintosh but the next computer was much
easier to develop for and that was a
place where this interface builder
technology which was sort of a graphical
interface for building interfaces um uh
existed um and teo made much use of that
you know i have to say one thing i'll
i'll be writing about in this piece that
i'm writing about the um the creation of
the nks book was um let me leave it as a
bit of a cliffhanger the bizarre bug in
postscript that we found uh sort of at
the last minute in printing the nks book
back in 2002 and the strange story of
tracking down that bargain and so on and
and uh it's strange that a bug would
have existed in postscript by 2002 given
the huge amount of um that have been
done with it by that time
anyway a little bit of a response on
that
um
it's uh
uh
okay i'm um
uh
okay
sandra is saying in the netherlands if
you dial
three one hash before the phone number
uh other people won't see your phone
number yeah yeah those things that what
is it in the u.s star eight six or
something like that that's the that's
the ani data
uh
what is it automatic name identification
code that gets sent before
the um uh when a phone connects to
another phone it sends a packet of
information about the originating
number and that's the thing there is
there are ways to blank that out at
least unless you're calling like an 800
number which which captures those things
um but that that's uh yeah
there are um there are there are a few
of those codes that exist um that are
sort of known
and um uh there are no doubt other ones
that are you know ten digits long that
um only only the people deep in the
bowels of the of the phone system
understand what those are
um
okay one comment here and then i'm
willing to go
um from captain here so is evolution a
bug or a feature
uh
is the fact that
it is
well you know it depends on what you're
looking at how you're looking at it i
mean i think that
the
was it to be expected that life
of the kind we have on on earth
could arise from
the the underlying physics that exists
in the universe
to us today
it still seems like a bug because we
don't know how it works
eventually it will probably seem like a
feature because we can trace the pieces
and say this is why it worked that way
but i think anything anything that's
still unexplained we could say was a bug
and it only becomes a feature when we
can have kind of a human narrative that
says how you can document it and make it
make sense that would be my my sort of
instant philosophy on that um on that
topic all right i think we have to wrap
up here actually i'm going to a a day
job live stream about language design uh
heading for version 13.1 of language
uh 35 years later that's what we get to
anyway thanks for all those interesting
questions i see there are a lot more to
be saved up for
uh for our session in a couple weeks
so thanks